hey how you doing today folks in today's
video I want to discuss John snow and
his legitimacy as a trueborn Targaryen
because I think the biggest theory in
television history was the r plus l
equals j theory and for years people
were always left wondering who the
mother of John snow was John was always
known as Ned Stark's bastard son but I
think most of the fans knew that the
secrecy around his mother had to be
something pretty big and more important
than what just lied on the surface Ned
Stark always claimed that John was his
son and that he basically just had with
some random woman during Robert's
rebellion but we knew that Ned was such
an honorable man that this couldn't be
true we knew that Ned had to have been
hiding something that was very important
about John's mother but was too
dangerous to reveal which is pretty
unfortunate for John to have to grow up
that way not knowing who his true
parents were because being a bastard is
a tough life even for a highborn kid in
a noble family like the Starks this was
something John had to live with and
accept no matter how he felt inside and
Catelyn didn't make it easy on John
either I think she was always jealous of
this mysterious woman that was able to
get the Honorable Ned Stark to break his
vows and even though it wasn't John's
fault she always made John feel unwanted
and always embarrassed him around
company by making him sit elsewhere or
sometimes not even allow him to attend
these get-togethers at all so as soon as
John was old enough to leave the house
he left to start a new life at Castle
black he wanted to join the Nights Watch
and protect the realm from what lies
beyond the wall which the Starks have
done for thousands of years and his John
left for Castle black Ned told him that
the next time they see each other he
would tell him about his mother but
unfortunately that would be the last
time that they would ever speak which
left us fans wondering would we ever
find out who John's real mother was but
thankfully as bran was beyond the wall
training to become the new three-eyed
raven we started to get a glimpse of
what actually happened and just to start
back a little bit years ago at the 20 of
Harrenhal
a young Lyanna stark sister to Ned Stark
was an attending
while the prince rhaegar targaryen
competed in and won this tournament and
after the tournament it was custom for
the winner to give the crown of roses to
the most beautiful woman in the crowd
which everyone assumed Rhaegar would
give them to his wife Elia Martell but
he actually rode right past her and laid
Deming lyanna stark's lap and that
gesture led to a bit of outrage and was
definitely frowned upon because not only
was Rhaegar married but Liana was also
be truth to another man who was Robert
Baratheon and at some point after the
tournament Liana was said to have been
abducted by Rhaegar and taken south to
Dorne and after this happened that's
when Leona's brother Brandon stark
wanted Rhaegar arrested and charged for
his crimes but Rhaegar father who was
the king at the time actually had
Brandon stark and his men charged for
treason and demanded that Brandon and
Leone his father come to King's Landing
for the trial and he promised that he
would have a fair trial but the Mad King
actually had him burned alive and put
Brandon stark in a device that
eventually strangled him so the sequence
of events led to the uprising of
Robert's rebellion and Ned was
determined to find his sister Liana and
that's when we see in brains vision Ned
Stark outside the Tower of joy which was
being guarded by Targaryen Kingsguard
and most notably Sir Arthur Dayne who
was a legendary swordsman at the time so
we knew that they had to have been
guarding someone or something very
important which we later found out was
the princes son and after a quick battle
that next stark almost lost but he ended
up dead defeating Sir Arthur Dayne with
the help of Howland Reed we see Ned
Stark go inside the tower where Lyanna
stark was inside giving birth to a baby
boy and that's when she asked Ned to
promise to keep her child's birth a
secret from Robert and that Ned claimed
the child as his own so that the child
wouldn't be killed
so we now knew that the child Ned
brought home from the war that was John
Snow was not his kid but actually his
sister Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen skit with HBO later confirmed
by showing John's lineage so now that or
plus L equals J has been
fun I think the biggest remaining
question is is John snow a legitimate
Targaryen or is he still a bastard and
there isn't a whole lot of information
two point one way or the other so this
is going to be just what I believe and I
think that if Rhaegar was willing to run
off with Liana while he was married and
she was betrothed to Robert knowing that
it would cause blood to be shed and
ultimately war I think he would have
found a way to marry her considering
what he was willing to risk and it
certainly wouldn't be the first time a
Targaryen had two wives at the same time
now with only thirteen episodes left in
the show they may not go into all the
details surrounding Jon's birth or
Rhaegar only on his relationship but
with two books still remaining to come
out by George or Martin these books
could potentially have upwards of 2,000
2,500 pages so I certainly believe he
will delve into this more in the books
because with more and more main
characters dying the story is really
going to shift its focus on Jon Snow who
is becoming the central character in the
story which will lead us to learning
more details about his bloodline and
legitimacy now it was always believed
that Rhaegar kidnapped and raped Leon a
stork but I actually believe that she
left with him willingly
I believe that she was infatuated with
him and swept off her feet by the young
prince who I think she eventually fell
in love with and Rhaegar was always held
in high regard by those who knew him or
fought beside him so he's always kind of
known as this nice guy in sir burst and
Selma even once said that he never liked
killing people but he did love this
scene and he also loved to play the
horror so to me it sounds like he's a
bit of a romantic guy he sounds like the
type of guy that would want to marry the
woman that he truly loved especially if
he knew she was expecting a child
he would definitely want the prince that
was promised to be legitimized he
wouldn't want the prince that was
promised to be a bastard but I also
think regardless of what Jon's last name
is it's not going to matter in the end
only his blood is important I don't
think John needs the Targaryen name to
rule even if he wanted
because by the end of the story the
population will have dwindled so much in
kings and queens as we know it will no
longer exist that if John wins in the
end they're going to raise him up as a
god no matter what his name is because
it's not the names that make this a Song
of Ice and Fire
but it's the blood that runs in their
veins and I definitely believe that John
is a legitimate Targaryen so comment
below and let me know what you guys
think
you think he was legitimized or is he
still a bastard I appreciate you guys
for listening thanks for the support and
I'll see you next time bye